scarlett johansson and snl star colin
jost yes these two are getting through
this pandemic together it also helps
that they're newlyweds look at you using
the wall i love that
colin talking all about their whirlwind
i do's to our lauren zema
what a first year of marriage if you can
make it through uh this
situation and uh it seems like a very
good sign
scar jost tied the knot almost four
months ago
so does that make colin an expert
wedding planner now because he kind of
looks like one in his new movie tom
and jerry your character he gets very
swept up in wedding planning
we're gonna release doves and then uh
maybe bigger like an eagle will come
catch the dove sort of drop it into a
dove area
were you that person uh no i was not i
was very
happy to um take a back seat
in in wedding planning department i i
it's not like i didn't
care about uh details i just didn't i
don't
pretend to know much about things okay
it sounds like you let
the bride kind of make all the decisions
i think i was
more i would say deferential i i never
grew up
imagining my dream wet like this is what
i want
you know i imagined my dream partner
rather than my dream wedding you found
your dream partner so your dream
realized
that was the thing that i was much
happier about getting right
we have an exclusive behind-the-scenes
look at how the live action and
animation hybrid movie
was made using puppets chloe grace
moretz michael pena and ken
jung also star ken's a swanky hotel chef
in the film
that brings the classic cartoon duo to
life i will not let this hotel be ruined
by a cat and a mouse
[Music]